if you're a marvel fan who likes to pour
over every frame looking for key details
this is for you these are the most
paused and most pause-worthy moments in
avengers end game
in the wake of captain america civil war
the various earth-bound heroes of the
mcu were divided in a way we hadn't seen
before
and the films that followed directly
commented on the fallout from those
events
spider-man homecoming showed us how tony
stark was carrying on and even looking
for new members to join the avengers
while also implying that captain america
was on the run black panther showed us
the isolation of wakanda in the
aftermath of king t'chaka's death
then avengers infinity war came along
and delivered cap's team of secret
avengers
traveling around the world to help where
they could what the film didn't give us
though
was any real presence from ant-man and
hawkeye
i'm so confused these are confusing
times
turns out that after civil war both
scott lang and clint barton were put
under house arrest for their roles in
helping cap scott got a whole movie
devoted to his predicament with ant-man
and the wasp but in-game was the first
film we saw
clint dealing with his own confinement
if you look closely in the film's cold
open
you can see the consequences if only for
a moment pause it just the right time
and you'll spot an ankle monitor around
barton's leg
similar to the one scott lang had to
wear when it comes to the world of
marvel comics and its translation to the
big screen there are some easter eggs
that will never get old we could never
get enough stan lee cameos
and it was always fun to see a famous
comic creator's name show up on a street
sign or a storefront
and of course die hard marvel fans are
always happy to see a certain
three-digit number
when avengers end game opens scott lang
is still trapped in the quantum realm
and he's only freed because a rat steps
on the controls for the quantum tunnel
in the back of his van which has long
since been moved into a storage unit
with the name
lang on the sign and beneath the name is
the unit's number
616. that number has long been
associated with the prime marvel
universe and the comics continuity the
reality where all of marvel's main
stories are set
there are multiple realities peter this
is earth dimension 616. i'm from
earth833
the 616 gag has been used before in the
films
dr selvig wrote it on a chalkboard in
thor the dark world for example
but it's always nice to pause for a
moment and just smile at the reference
avengers infinity war had to pack on a
lot of plot
into an already long movie which means
that there were plenty of questions from
the film that endgame needed to spend
some time answering
one of those loose ends was a character
from thor ragnarok who became a fan
favorite and then was conspicuously
absent from the brutal
opening of infinity war so what happened
to thor's rocky pal
korg my name is cork i'm kind of like
the leader in here
made of rocks as you can see but don't
let that intimidate you
you don't need to be afraid unless
you're made of scissors thankfully
avengers end game lets us know early on
that korg and his best friend meek
survived the slaughter of the asgardians
and are now living with thor
at the new asgard on earth like the god
of thunder
both former gladiators have become couch
potatoes hanging out in the house
all day and playing video games it's a
funny reveal but it includes more than
just the news that korg is alive
if you freeze the scene on one of korg's
shots you might notice that he's adopted
some earth clothes
namely a pineapple print shirt and
shorts it might seem like just a funny
costume
choice but it's actually a nod to the
actor who plays
korg thor ragnarok director taika
waititi
who's been known to walk a red carpet or
two in a pineapple printed romper
stan lee was a constant presence in the
world of marvel-based films for decades
thanks to his many
many cameo appearances after popping up
in the more separated universes of the
spider-man and x-men trilogies
lee became a prominent fixture of the
mcu appearing in nearly
every marvel studios film in one form or
another to the delight of fans
sadly lee passed away in the fall of
2018 at the age of 95
and avengers end game marked the last
time we'd see lees
instantly recognizable face in a new
cameo thankfully for all of us
it was a memorable appearance lee showed
up at the beginning of tony stark and
steve rogers time heist in new jersey in
1970
speeding past an army base in a muscle
car lee's retro look for the cameo is
reason enough to freeze the frame
but if you pause at the very beginning
of the scene and look at this car you'll
notice enough said bumper sticker
prominently displayed
along with excelsior nuff said became
one of stan the man's most popular
catchphrases back in the days when he
was still
writing regular letter columns in the
pages of marvel comics
and it's a nice nod to the stan of the
70s you know
i guess one person can make a difference
nuff said though he might not have the
same high profile as characters like
captain america
thor or iron man the superhero known as
ant-man is
actually one of the oldest characters in
the marvel universe hank pym and his
incredible shrinking powers debuted all
the way back in 1962
in the pages of tales to astonish and
the character went on to become a
founding member of the avengers
pym's long journey to the big screen
meant that by the time we finally
did see him in the mcu the story focused
more on the second ant-man
scott lang hi
i'm scott did he just say hi i'm scott
and it made pam into a legacy hero whose
adventures in his prime we see only in
flashback
however avengers endgame offers an
opportunity to pay homage to this legacy
with a time
travel trip back to 1970 when pam was
still a young doctor working in a shield
lab
though pym's end game time is little
more than a cameo appearance we get to
see a brief glimpse of an early ant-man
helmet
on a table in his lap if you pause to
admire the headgear for a moment
you'll see that it's a design lifted
from pym's very earliest comic book
appearances
avengers game is three hours of pure
comic book fueled adrenaline so there
are plenty of moments worth hitting the
pause button on
if we had to pick just one though if
there was only one scene
in the film worth freeze framing over
and over again it's the moment when the
story's climax kicks into high gear
steve rogers battled and hobbled by his
battle with thanos
refuses to stop fighting he stands up as
thanos army gathers on the horizon
prepared to go down swinging in the
battle to save the earth
then he hears his friend sam wilson's
voice in his head and the portals open
up all around him
suddenly captain america is surrounded
by an army of allies from wakanda
the sanctum sanctorum and beyond the
crowd that gathers so
cap can at long last say those famous
words
assemble it's truly an amazing site and
it's worth pausing on to highlight as
many characters as possible
bonus points if you can find howard the
duck in the ranks
the build-up to the climactic battle is
an amazing moment full of appearances
from resurrected heroes and plenty of
freeze frame worthy shots
even after all that build up has landed
though the showdown itself
offers plenty of individual spotlight
sequences that are worth focusing on
as the camera zooms through the massive
battlefield virtually every major marvel
character gets at least one moment to
shine
it's a glorious series of moments but
one in particular seems to stand out
above the rest
at one point in the battle our heroes
decide they need to get the infinity
gauntlet
over to the quantum tunnel to keep it
away from thanos as peter parker tries
to hand the gauntlet over to carol
danvers
every major female hero in the fight
surrounds her and they prepare for an
all-out assault on thanos forces
is it a move that feels like pure fan
service to some maybe
but creating a team of all female
avengers known in the comics as
a-force if even for a few seconds is
still cheer-worthy as
is their charge into battle seconds
later the arc of the overall mcu
sometimes builds slowly in the
background but it's there
and avengers endgame made that
especially clear by serving as both a
loving guide to the mcu's past
and a conclusion to the story of tony
stark the film is an emotional
devastating ending to tony's journey
from selfish tech genius
to savior of the universe and the payoff
of that journey feels like a satisfying
conclusion to not just
this film but the decade of movies that
came before this all culminates in the
avengers holding a memorial service for
tony
outside his family home and the camera
lovingly pans across what's essentially
the universe he created
as the first mcu hero we see each
franchise represented in turn
all given suitable reverence but then
the camera briefly hovers across a sad
young man standing by himself
as moviegoers scratch their heads and go
huh if you or someone in your home is
still confused about that kid at the
funeral
hit pause and study his features he's
grown up a lot so it's understandable if
you didn't recognize him at first but
that's actually
harley keener the budding child inventor
from iron man 3 who helped a stranded
tony stark when he most needed a friend
i would have added in um the retro
retro reflective panel to make him
stealth mode you want a stealth mode
cool right
it's actually a good idea in other words
harley more than earned his spot at that
funeral
back in avengers infinity war thanos
promises that if he gets what he wants
he'll finally go someplace to rest
proud of the years of labor it took to
finally make his dreams a reality
in endgame we get to see what that rest
looks like and for thanos at least it
seems rather nice
wounded and weak in the wake of his
battle with the avengers and his effort
to destroy the infinity stones once and
for all
the film finds thanos at home on an
isolated garden planet
harvesting crops and relaxing in what
looks like a simple hut
he's also found a new use for the armor
he wore through all his years of
fighting
it's now a scarecrow watching over his
fields on the surface
this is a nice symbol an indication that
thanos has indeed committed to no longer
fighting anything or anyone
before the avengers show up he seems
truly relaxed and content in his new
surroundings and the scarecrow is a good
indication of that
but marvel comics fans know that the
imagery carries a deeper meaning
if you pause the movie at this point and
then go back and look at the final pages
of the classic 1991 story the infinity
gauntlet
you'll see a direct parallel to the end
of that story in which thanos is exiled
to live out his days as a simple farmer
after his defeat in the wake of the snap
each of the surviving avengers learn to
cope in their own way
steve starts support groups bruce learns
how to deal with both halves of himself
thor descends into a life of booze and
video games
tony starts a family and clint goes on
the warpath after losing his wife and
kids
then there's natasha who decides her
place is in the avengers compound in
upstate new york where she coordinates
superhero operations on earth and beyond
because it's the only thing she knows
how to do
she also apparently takes some solace in
certain aspects of her past
i used to have nothing
and then i got this in the scene where
steve visits natasha at the compound
one wide shot reveals an interesting nod
to natasha's unconventional upbringing
if you pause at the right moment you'll
see a pair of ballet shoes on a chair
this is a nod to natasha's past as a
young girl trained to be a russian
assassin
the ballet was part of the physical
training along with her journey to
becoming a cold-blooded killer
and perhaps as she grew older it was one
of the few things she still enjoyed
about that period in her life
we'll learn more about natasha's past in
the black widow solo film
and this little easter egg is a nice nod
in that direction
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you